what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
fresh and fit video titled
kick her out if she breaks these five
five rules
as a girl i'm just curious what five
rules get me kicked to the curb before i
start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay kicker i just want to know do i get
kicked to the curb
[Music]
if a chick isn't [ __ ] you she's not
respecting you she's not sucking your
dick on command she's not making you
food
she's not serving you she's useless i'm
gonna say that again
wow i don't care if we get monetized
if a girl isn't [ __ ] you sucking your
dick serving you
making you food keeping the house clean
and up i do not like myron
i do not like him at all um
okay so i would just keep listening
holding
her feminine characteristics of what
she's supposed to do kick her to the
curb
because i'm gonna tell you this as a man
i know for a fact
you have to bring value to the table to
deal with this [ __ ] girl nine out of
ten times all she has to do
is just bring her looks and some
femininity okay
and last time i checked she's gonna
expect you to deal with that [ __ ]
poor girl and this is
this is what i genuinely think about
like so often when he talks like this
like
what if your wife gets sick what if she
physically
cannot do those things for you
then do you kick her to the curb
um when he breaks in so that [ __ ]
better suck some goddamn dick
all right if a girl is doing that
[ __ ] you
and you like that's so that's so sad
that he's just
valuing women for literally just their
looks
and their sexual value i have never been
a fan of the way he like talks about
women he comes off as very
um almost bitter at times towards women
and i don't know why but his like
confidence doesn't seem very real to me
like it seems very like
i don't know women can just sniff this
out girls will know what i'm talking
about i think it's funny like when i say
yo uh if a girl doesn't let you have sex
or whatever just kick her out whatever
she's your girl she's not giving you sex
anymore you gotta kick her you gotta get
rid of her
you need to get rid of her because she
doesn't respect you anymore okay
the sex is a personification of her
respect for you and how much she likes
you
a woman that's low interest and doesn't
respect you is going to [ __ ] hurt you
man
you guys get what i'm saying i do agree
with this partially
like if um i mean it depends how long
like
if your wife hasn't like what if your
wife just had a baby
and this is what i think of is like
you're gonna like
kick your wife to the curb if she
doesn't want to have sex because she
just had a
kid um but i do agree with what he's
saying like i think
where he's coming from is like a place
of i've been hurt by women
that um where i did all this this this
and this
and she had no interest in wit in me so
in order to protect yourself fellas
do this this and this i understand where
he's coming from she's gonna
hurt you and when she doesn't respect
you she's gonna hurt you in a way
that you might not be able to recover
from because you're already in a place
where you've allowed her to disrespect
you you're already invested
you continue to invest more because a
lot of guys make that cardinal mistake
of thinking
oh she doesn't like me let me just
invest more let me buy her that bag let
me take her on this trip let me do this
let me tell y'all [ __ ] something man
women is the one thing
where you invest more money more
resources more time
the more you lose it's not like building
on your purpose and focusing on yourself
when you invest in yourself you win i do
agree with him on this he talks a lot
about self improvement and investing in
yourself as a man
i definitely agree with that part of
what he's talking about and i
can definitely see the value in putting
your purpose above
um like other things in your life when
you invest in women
you lose you want to know why because
women are the one thing
that men don't understand because
they're what ill [ __ ] logical
and this is what i don't understand i
want to
know if he's even witnessed and like has
friends that have successful long-term
marriages because
i look at like my parents like they've
been married like going on like 30 years
um and when you're married that long
you're not like
counting down who does more for who and
like if you're investing too much in a
woman
like they both do a lot for each other
and that's the thing about marriage is
you
both have to put in a hundred percent
it's not like
don't do too much for your partner and i
don't care what any angry feminists want
to say whatever it is
it's and i really would like to say i'm
i'm the furthest thing from an angry
feminist
so i hate it when the comment section
comes at me and they're like oh you're
just a feminist you're brainwashed
because i'm really not i just genuinely
don't see i could see him maybe like
pulling girls but i don't see him having
a successful long-term relationship
i don't see half of these dating coaches
having like the mental
stability to have that counterproductive
tool
oh god i know the comment section is
going to come over invest in women and
it's going to hurt you
so you need to know this and that's the
thing like they're coming from a place
of like being hurt
and if you go into relationships of like
for coming from a place of being
hurt it's gonna be harder
ain't [ __ ] you sucking you making you
food whatever it is just understand and
you want it and she tells you no
just understand that respect is
dwindling she's probably looking at
other guys
because a woman can't serve two masters
if she loves you she's gonna do
everything she can for you
get ready to kick her to the curb and
you need to be
ready to do it at a moment's notice when
women i'll tell you guys this
listen to this song future too
comfortable okay
[ __ ] don't get too comfortable when
women are comfortable
problems arise you need her on her
[ __ ] toes at all times thinking like
damn
is he gonna break up with me damn he's
really honest [ __ ] damn
like this is what i can guarantee you my
parents have been
married a very long time and
my mom and dad were not constantly
wondering
if they were going to break up with the
other
you made a lot of money again this
probably works in short-term
relationships i'm guarantee this works
in like getting girls whatever getting
like what you want
sexually but i come from like
a very different lifestyle than that you
know what i'm saying
it is what it is man he who cares less
in a relationship has the leverage and
you know what on this podcast i'm gonna
tell y'all [ __ ]
the uncomfortable truth keep your
[ __ ] foot on her neck
she needs to know that she could be
replaced at any time
oh my god i cannot imagine can you
imagine dating a guy like that
you can be replaced at any time
when she she has that fear that she
might lose you
she's going to be on her best friend
don't physically put your foot on her
and what i'm saying is i don't i do see
i understand what he's saying like he's
saying
that like make sure you're valuable
enough
like instead of like threatening or
sorry i'm trying to phrase this
correctly because you guys are very
touchy in the way i say things
but
instead of caring make making sure
you're the one
that cares less less being ready to kick
her to the curb dead
like all that nonsense why don't you
just be the best version of yourself and
give her something that she's afraid to
lose
[Music]
i'm just using it to like you know an
analogy right
don't really do that guys don't be you
know i'm saying stupid but
what i am saying is that you need to
keep the leverage guys
when you have the leverage in a
relationship i promise you the
relationship is gonna be better
you're gonna get that hypergamy tickle
satisfied
and she's gonna know you are the best
that she can get i need y'all [ __ ] to
turn into [ __ ] gillette
okay okay
yeah this is probably why that's my
least favorite channel to react to
i think they got some good advice like i
definitely agree with him on like the
self-improvement
um be with someone who values you that's
totally true but if you're in a
relationship where you have to wonder
like
who likes who more you have to be ready
to kick her to the curb at a moment's
notice do you really see that working in
a long term like 20 30
40 50 year marriage um and if you do let
me know why
in the comments it just doesn't seem
very wise to me
personally um because at some point you
really just have to love the person that
you're with
because it's the stuff really going to
matter when you're 60 70 80 years old
like but let me know in the comments do
not forget to subscribe
to the channel um and bring the
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time